[Music]
guys
guys we're doing we keep talking about
the new york times a couple years ago
the failing new york times by the way
somebody made t-shirts
the family new york times in the same
logo and i wanted
it so it's such a great joke and i
should have bought the i don't know who
made it but it like the quality wasn't
good
they're not good they're not meant for
quality right yeah it's like ah
guy if you this is a great joke you put
this on a nice fabric print like that's
great
if i find good ones can i buy them for
us
yeah i'll wear them on the show yeah the
failing time
um okay so they had a thing
which was 36 questions that will make
you and a
another person fall in love and for
years
well a year and change 69 episodes
[Music]
this is episode 70. um
so we're going to do the questionnaire
36 questions
and we're going to fall in love
so say goodbye to the old neil and the
old bianca
what's happening goodbye everybody
ladies if you're a pining
it's just you're just i'm missing
relegating you to a fan
maybe side check you'll get sidetracked
he's mine now
ladies because back off um bianca before
he went on the air said that
cheating is not it's a long story
yeah and everyone would agree with me
thank you um
it's for a different time um
okay there are three sets of questions
um and uh
let us begin okay
number one set one number one
given the choice of anyone in the world
who would you want as a dinner guest
let's go living or dead oh yeah i
thought living or dead you go first
i'm gonna go first i've thought about
this
it's always the three people but the
problem with three people is
you have to worry about chemistry yeah
and diets
then you know what i mean like if you
get benjamin franklin he wants to eat
like do you have any fish stew and
you're like dog
yeah turtle please no one no one's
eating turtle like i'm not
doing that [ __ ] so let's assume we're
eating crossroads or
sage vegan bistro because because i'm
welcome to the future
gents my guest this is based on
i don't need him to or her to
care about me i just want to hear the
person talk
in person [ __ ] this is hard
oh i thought you no i know i i thought i
i james baldwin ugh
james bond because my favorite thing
about james baldwin is
if he were white he would talk like
hannibal actor
he's black hannibal actor and he eats
white people right
for with a
how long is it going to take for you how
long how long do i have to
wait for your progress yes it's like
yeah it's [ __ ] amazing it's like
moony it's mooney
he's moony he's less sassy moony
yeah he's and he's so [ __ ] smart
it's dizzying but i thought of malcolm x
at the same time
i thought someone either
like from the civil rights movement or
the harlem renaissance i was like
somebody in there and i thought about it
and i looked i'm like
i can't choose because of course i want
to choose james baldwin but
i think he also has these great clips
you know these great sound bites just
based on like where he was
in his life and i feel like there are
still those
figures in those two eras there's i feel
like there's a lot of
comparable like um really passionate
speakers really compelling speakers like
him not a lot but
he really sticks out obviously because
he's great but i
i don't know it has to be someone from
you haven't picked anybody i can't i
can't because i was looking i said i was
looking up
just reminding myself of all the figures
in the harlem renaissance i'm like [ __ ]
like
langston hughes like like all these
people like i would want
i can't choose this is gonna make me not
fall in love with you
that's okay i'm fine with that um
so we learned
mine's james while when bianca's is
a one of 100 people and she doesn't want
to
offend any of them because even though
they're all dead
and she doesn't want to get this is why
because you cannot make a decision i
just not that one it's like
you're gonna you have to make a decision
we can't
move on no you have to make it magazine
no i don't know any
like literally anybody links in here
okay great number two
would you like to be famous in what way
i would like to be a famous comedian
one day you'll get one day i will get
there i'm not unknown
i i don't know what i am i i don't think
i i don't know what i am and i don't
think i ever will
you're you're you're a little
you're weird because you're kind of
inside baseball comic
but then a lot of people know you yeah
that
don't even [ __ ] with comedy
yes like heavy more chappelle show yeah
and
um a lot of people don't know that you
wrote half-baked
because i was like oh yeah he wrote how
big he wrote that day
like yes he did it's starting to feel
like another one
yeah oh yeah well you're old like i used
to brag about it and now
like i was talking to a bunch of girls
last night and they were all stoned and
i was gonna go like you know and then i
was like i don't even [ __ ] care
i just don't i don't know there's [ __ ]
in it that i like but mo
whatever it's like a worse it's just a
shitty good don't say [ __ ] it's very
good but
of chappelle show it's very um yes i
don't now having said that
i don't think my life would get better
by being famous
i would be busier i would be more
have more cachet but
the people that you want cachet with i
have it
with right dominicans okay
uh so there's no i don't know
money i don't know i yeah i don't know i
don't the money wouldn't make a
difference this doesn't say
rich and famous right but i'm saying why
famous would you like to be famous
i think i'm richer than i am famous yeah
you have hella money
i get you you think you would think i'm
deduced yeah um
i don't i know that it's corrosive for
your character
so in closing yes i would like to be
famous i would like to be
a guy who does theaters all the time
yeah
i would like to be sebastian burr that
in that yeah
um and again the more the delays and the
louies get disqualified
it's mario kart and he slipped on a
banana they keep slipping up banana
is it banana peels or coconut shells
banana field great thank you
um i would like let's see i
don't know because yeah to a certain
degree of course like
we do this show it's nice to be known so
yes but
i guess it's like define being famous
because there's a lot of famous people
that just do their thing
and are famous for the job they do in
this industry and then there's people
who go out of their way to like
go to the ivy and be famous so i
wouldn't want that i think that's
weird and that's a weird sleeping bear
that wants you awake
you you have you're talking about like
tab tmz
tabloid well some people really do want
to be instagram
like just famed known at any cost just
known
have their billings be higher at all
costs
i don't want that i want to make all of
my money through entertainment
i would that's what you like the
fame that you get from
doing this do you like the recognition
whatever you how would you even just
describe it
i do but i it's not it's a little like
i um i i like it of course in certain
ways you know people want to be
recognized and like oh hey
binky blah blah blah but at the same
time
uh it feels like you have more of a
target and i
and no one even [ __ ] knows me really
so if i feel
like a little heat right now most of
it's very good heat
but heat is eat baby and when the heat
is
um bad faith and just doesn't like
like kind of just doesn't like you and
and i feel like i did go on me i don't
really read the comments i don't really
care
i i don't really need to get into it
with people if you think i suck that's
fine
it's not like my job like let me show
you i'm cool yeah but
that can be a little toxic stressful so
um i would need the fame and the money
it need to be worth it you know what i
mean like if you're making a lot of
money it's like wow that's like what you
want what the [ __ ] i
have 100 million dollars but the people
who are just
famous and like not really
monetarily i feel like what that's a
nightmare yeah what are you doing so you
have
oh they're not doing any it just
happened to them yeah
that's that's to me that's a nightmare
so i would like to be
known for
[ __ ] as that i'm doing for a job i don't
want to just be like famous like follow
me and like but
what do you make of the heat the heat
and the
toxic attention i think that comes with
it so you can't if you want it that
comes with it but i think you can
mitigate it
so that if you don't feed into it a
little bit if you don't
like if you want if ego-wise you want to
be famous it's all ego but
if you're like i want that attention i
want to be
recognized when i go play all that all
the amenities famous
i think that comes with way more heat i
don't want that heat i don't want the
heat
so you might not want to be famous no i
like to be but i think you could be
famous for
doing something and not just you're
still going to get the heat though you
know the i understand that i
said the heat for being famous is fine
but the heat for being
just like if you want season 9 of
no no no no no no
no if you want to be recognized when you
go into place and have people kind of
kiss your ass all over the place that
feeding your ego thing that like
extra level i think that just comes with
a lot more heat
you or like comparable people can just
be famous for a thing
and go about their day you don't need a
lot of ass kissing you don't need people
to
but when you do work you're respected i
think that is ideal
i don't need it to be like
people running up to me type [ __ ]
because i think that comes with a
storybook did i tell the story about ron
and pharaoh and
yeah which one they don't love it when
they i saw him at a restaurant
no john lovett john lovett and ronan
couple
i think i think no they're not married
um and love it
not hey not the liar the john lovett
who's a speech writer for obama and he
he does positive america but they when
pods of america first started to get
popular
i saw him and ronan at a bar at
crossroads and
they looked and had like a weird look in
their face like oh what's going on they
go
the bartender just gave us drinks
like what which this never happened
before like what do we do
because ronan was starting to get known
for his articles
drink them no i go oh
here's the thing you got to tip them
and here's the bad news it will end up
costing you more
than it would have you just paid just
pay but you can't
say i just i'll just pay because you
still once they
you so there's [ __ ] like that that's not
that's like the kind of the funny one
the bad one is like the like gunning for
you i'm gonna kill you
i'ma i'm gonna kill you you're canceled
you're a [ __ ] um
uh okay okay so fame
yes from neil yeah qualified yes from
berzinky um hard to get a straight
answer
bianca will not fold under questions
it's like the first 48
and she don't know that [ __ ] i
never seen
him this is a good question number three
before making a telephone call do you
ever rehearse what you're going to say
why never i read this i'm like who the
[ __ ] does that
i first of all since i started listening
to the effect of communication class i'm
on
i'm on go around number two now
listening to it for a second time
uh you hear new things every every time
um
yeah i i think i think about it a lot
and then there are times where when i
don't think about it i'm like [ __ ] dude
you needed
i i want to get in the practice of sorry
of when i have a phone call anytime i
have an interaction with someone i want
to
freeze time and go you 93
of communication is tone and facial
expressions that's
the that's the statistic seven percent
of it is words
now i had it flipped no wonder why i
never have a bad
conversation yes i thought it's all
words
all lyrics bars bars bars but no
it's all beat and melody it's [ __ ]
has nothing to do with what you say
that's
i can like i should be a hostage crisis
man like i can
d d um
what is it do you like escalante
de-escalate a conversation
really like if i see it i'm like oh it's
not going well like
just especially with strangers or like
something where you're like oh
this person's energy like that you took
it this way it's
this way it's those kind of that's all
tone that's all sink that's a lullaby
and good night fall asleep little baby
yep so it really is mostly that how have
you
have you been i it's hit or miss uh
sometimes i do
sometimes i make a concerted effort and
really but then like you guys are coming
over
and i'm in the shower and then i don't
and then i'm
wills doing [ __ ] with the lights and
you're like yeah i get a little shitty
and then
i think i'm being i think i'm and then
i'm like no this is not
good tone good faith yeah you know what
the
the the um acronym is fat
face and tone but because i'm fat phobic
i've gone with taff
tone and face
second question the second question is
i used to this is where the codependency
comes in okay
i would get so lost i was so lost in
some of my codependent relationships
that when i had a phone call planned
or scheduled or whatever we're going to
talk tomorrow whatever
i would have a index card with
my the things i wanted to say before i
started
what do you mean like if it was in a
relationship yeah if it was in a
relationship with
yeah if it was like not a kind of a talk
like a big talk
yeah um but that's good yeah but that so
that's what i mean like there are times
where
i have in my life very much
been good at it use it as a tool
because i don't want to forget it's
important that i remember this
and it's important that i discuss this
on this call
it's funny because um when i realized
when i was young in high school and
junior high my friends
my friends circled that was we were
regular kids but
whenever we had a problem with each
other i would say like
once every month and a half we'd all sit
down at a table we all had a binder
paper of lists that we needed
of grievances we needed to air and we
would it would be a long life
all girls and we would air it out and
they were funny i found one when i was
home
the other day and it was like you stole
my you took my light you borrowed my
lighter
and you didn't give it back you do that
a lot that was my purple lighter it was
like the dumbest [ __ ]
but it didn't matter what we were saying
it i really think
that working through it with your
friends
and having to say we said the dumbest
shit's like you brag that you're in
brad's car
it was so stupid i gotta say it's really
adult
i can't think of a of a friend group or
worker that wouldn't benefit from that
it was immensely valuable
and i because i can do it there when
your
hormones are raging and you're really
emotional and most kids don't even know
how to talk about their feelings
because we would and they would be rough
like some people would just get
like a pile on if people were not
behaving well
i had a girlfriend who said that they
used to do lemon squeezes
which is that but meaner what's lemon
squeezies they would pick a girl
and they would basically squeeze a l
proverbially squeeze a lemon
emotionally squeeze a lemon on her burns
like a lemon squeeze like we're gonna
[ __ ] dip you in acid
we're gonna fire citric acid you we
would they would just [ __ ] on her
they would like criticize her no that's
not what we did at all no i i get that
this was like the mean girl version of
that
yours sounds constructive ours is just
like hey i have an issue with you that's
building can we talk about it and then
it's like let's all just talk let's air
it out yeah and we did it so often that
it was
nobody took it personal like once we
talked about it we like forgot
people get defensive or they would be
like interesting
no the defensive but really like okay
well i didn't know i was doing that like
it wasn't like
[ __ ] you like it was just calm cool
collected
and then everybody would improve a
degree or two but everybody
always improved did you ever say like
you're getting written up
no you haven't heard the last i can't
imagine if this was you and yours
writing it down but no i don't do that
with phone calls because
i feel like i've i have really good
communication skills to get through
hard conversations so i kind of
i think i have the the like the luck of
being able to just
wing it yeah and go based on like oh how
are we doing now oh it's risen okay
like i can figure the temperature out as
we go you know what i mean i read a book
about anger once and they said
part of people people like me who aren't
prone to anger
quickly it's part of the reason
is because i'm growing up and even in
the world
i've never seen a
conflict de-escalate
peacefully like i've never seen in
modeling my parents it was just like my
dad was such a narcissist he had to win
so my mom right so and he would scream
screams and stream we're all kids
huh so i've never seen
something handled amicably it's all
force
and you can tell you can you've seen it
but also
i a lot of people have your same
experience
the amount of times i've had
conversations let's say with exes and
i'm like this doesn't need to be a fight
but he's never
seen yeah a peaceful art you've never
seen
two people just work want to solve it
let's just work through this and then i
remember
one dude was like oh okay like
that actually felt like it felt there's
resolution yeah
we i was like yeah the day doesn't have
to be ruined
we can move on and it and
after talking about it
that's actually funny yeah it's that was
in a book
uh there's a really good book about
anger that was my original that was the
uh effect of communication from two
years ago yeah
what would constitute a perfect day for
you
it's a great question i know i would
wake up
i would wake up earlier than i normally
wake up because i would like to wake up
early
but i my body doesn't want to but i
always enjoy
being up early same thing but i just my
body no my body's like
it's like that's not who we are um
get up earlier than i would like than i
normally do
i would eat my fruit
wow it would uh so right there
perfect eat my fruits
have a good idea for something
sketch joke thing for dying what
some good idea write a joke
exercise in the
iron paradise behind me that you can't
see
um and uh
sex com
some kind of sex
that's very selfish
completely selfish like straight up like
i'm on the phone and and i get a [ __ ]
how about that why i don't know
easier it's easier
it appeals to my ego and most male sex
fantasies are about ego
they're not about connection at all it's
more about like nine chicks
and they got it's inconvenient for them
and they're [ __ ]
fighting each other to get out my [ __ ]
um so that and then
a nice dinner and stand up
oh and then ice cream oh ice cream of
course
mine would be get up earlier than usual
when i get up early
i feel like i entered a whole new world
like human beings are doing this at this
time of the world
uh so get up earlier exercise
immediately feel good um
i don't know it would be a at 85 degrees
with
breeze warm breeze i'm very sensitive to
weather
uh after that it could be like a jumble
of like i don't know meeting up with
friends
because i like hanging out with my
friends i would like to add that i
would i would like to put in a long
phone call
with an interesting funny person
like a one to two hour phone call
somewhere that's funny
because i was like i want to put in a
really long conversation person
yeah i don't know if you're like okay
um and then friends good phone call
just get it just receive sorry no it's
not good phone call good conversation
but
i would like to receive a phone call of
like
good news a good news phone call
a good news work phone call i like it
yeah i like a good news work phone call
that's about
work in the future that is you
you don't have to do you have to do it
now you got it
you got the job we're going to send it
off we're going to send money now
send money the money the checks the
checks that's at your door ding dong
ding dong um perfect day every day
sorry i'm getting my dicks on the phone
perfect day so then
uh lots of so then a section for
very good sex that is not like yours i
don't want someone going down on me
while i'm on the phone
um suit yourself i was trying to take
your phone call the next level
no i don't want to look i'll leave you
ladies and gentlemen i want to lie there
and hang out not just lie there first of
all
somebody made that i won't say who made
an observation that women's
the requirements for women to be good
and bad most of what you're doing is
lying there
or standing there there is but guys you
gotta work it
dude you guys are dude
that's why i'm happy like except for my
nose i don't want to say that um
i cracked myself up uh
what was he saying okay good sex
then go to dinner because i don't like
having sex when i'm full
interesting um and then just go to like
a bomb ass
like japanese sushi
seafood mixed with japanese beef
wagyu like five grade a5
wagyu boom and then
um just like uh just
in the night warm night hang out outside
have a night cap go to bed oh that would
be so nice
yeah great i feel like ours are doable
uh
i would like to write like a new
documentary after ice cream like
arrow morris or uh adam curtis
or ezra edelman if he ever makes another
one yeah
um so great day guys
number four great day five when did you
last sing to yourself
when did you last sing to someone else i
feel like we sing just before we
recorded this yes i was saying i think i
was saying you're seeing something
i was singing what were you singing
james blake sent me a new song or he
i saw him and his lovely
living lady
chambermaid
and he gave me a new song and it's
[ __ ]
amazing uh-huh and uh
and then i sang it so i've just i
listened on a repeat
and sang it and
the last time i sang to somebody else
was i was dropping off weights
at their house
because i had i have an ex-girlfriend
was
yoga three five pound weight so i had a
bunch of three and five pound weights
jamilah haven't asked me about them
and um when so i brought them over and
james headed to the door and i happened
to be seeing his song
but i but it's one of my favorite things
to do is singing
singing someone's song to them oh that's
funny i love singing green light to john
legend
that's only a that's a sentence only
someone with kindness friends because i
know it's
here's a good one everyone's famous so
don't worry i'm not
named i'm not go ahead this is
like maybe chappelle show just started
and me and dave went to a nick game and
so it wasn't like the hottest [ __ ] in
the world
um we're on the elevator and jay-z and
and dame dash get on
and some weird [ __ ] talking and
jay's like i'm making another record i'm
i'm work man i work
and dave goes rockefeller y'all
it's just a [ __ ] very funny did
everybody laugh
not really that's the great thing the
great thing is they didn't even
realize how how like like [ __ ] inside
this joke it's so like they're so beyond
they do it for real right and he's like
and he was doing it like
are you ronnie like i don't even know
that's hilarious yeah like he meant it
but no but it's also like
let's do the thing you love to do your
favorite thing
uh yeah i last time saying to myself was
today
i was singing i think it's diane reeves
best better days it's a song to her
grandma
it's so goddamn good she was in the
supremes
no i don't know she was the kelly
rowland of the uh
to to uh to
[Music]
to to beyonce ross uh
i'm not sure actually but she's great
though
she's great and i just love um 80s r b
i love all r b but like that 80s that's
really kind of
cheesy a ballad like luther
andros yeah like i just love really
cheesy r
b that
instrument palette does nothing for me
i know it's it's like a little elevator
music e but it's dude dude there's so
many
good i'm gonna i'm gonna make you a mini
playlist
listen to me i i won't i won't you i
just won't you don't like it
no i just really don't i it does it just
bounces right off me like soul music i
could listen to [ __ ] like i know this
is
isaac hayes that that palette like
curtis mayfield like the [ __ ]
stax record [ __ ] and if you just said
you have to listen for the rest of your
life nothing else be like okay
yeah but that i would kill myself it's
like really synthy they're like
it's so cheesy and a lot of echo and
with like congratulations
um but it's funny too because i always
have like these weird 80s
rv playlists on youtube i make and
the the videos are so bad it's like
ah an old friend passed me by and then
like
it's just narrating the the videos in
the 80s were
just what was happening happened in the
song in the song
let's shoot it i was at the beach
you know we're shooting this the [ __ ]
beat it's so
funny and it's going to be you're going
to be
by yourself with a dog sing to someone
else was happy birthday last week i sang
to my friend
wonderful if you were able to live to
the age of 90
and retain either the mind or body of a
30 year old
for the last 60 years of your life which
would you want got it uh would i rather
have the mind
so if i were if i were 85
would i want the body of a 30 year old
and the mind of a 30 year old or would i
want
the body of an 85 year old and the mind
of an 85
no it's saying like at 30 would you want
to keep
if you were able to live to the age of
90 and retain the mind or body of a 30
year old for the last 60 years
yeah so at 30 you you have to decide
yeah what you want am i going to age in
body or age and mind
yeah i would keep body
what i already have an old mind
i have i do a podcast and there's a
segment called
neil's old man phrases now will probably
won't play it
because why would he do that
boom see where sarcasm will get you and
that's
the fat shaming face and tone
system at work i often fall short guys
hooked on fat when you've been up
sarcastic prick for 46 years
it's hard to do it's really hard to turn
that off turn it around
especially it really served you in a lot
of ways
it's like got me a nice house being a
sarcastic person okay what if
will jumps off the third floor of this
of this house
uh we gotta uh i think he'd live
there is oh yeah there's a way to i
think he'd live there's avocado trees on
one so he'd do it there's a pond on that
side
koi pond um yeah you know what
i thought the other way but you're
making a lot of sense because your mind
like
my 30 year old mind was capable of
learning i don't
i i don't think my i would still read
in some ways i feel like my mind is
stuck on a 10 year old's mind
in in some ways yeah no i i think you're
right i think body is the way
right way to go because you still it's
not like you're a
like got a lobotomy you're still yes you
have a friend and also
people hate old people
because they look old they look er they
look like they're on they're close to
death yeah it's like
did it like get something no they don't
get any respect
it's all vanity it's [ __ ] i know and
it's so [ __ ] up because everything
in america i think it's different yeah
but we
all ate yeah oh in france that was why i
loved france
uh everyone is sexy yeah
a 50 year old sexy french lady is gonna
get hit on
and looked at the same way a young girl
they're same with italy
yeah italy they're just big sunglasses
[ __ ] on
50 year old [ __ ] on on mopeds or
sunglasses forget it
shut it down menopause menopause have
you been in italy
i've been in italy a lot actually why i
dated a girl who lived in rome
for a second how long did you date her
uh it was sort of casual but
i think i went two or three times that's
a lot yeah
me and dave went one time for like a
month a week
did shrooms in rome was that that like
few years ago when you guys were in no
this was like
15 years ago during chapel show we went
i've only been to sardinia how you like
well i saw rihanna so that's kind of
worth it pretty cool
why where was she she was at this like
it was like a
boat party thing great
don't mind if i do thanks so old people
sorry but if you had a better body
you wouldn't have this problem this is
interesting
what is it do you have a secret hunch
about how you will die
yes do you really so here's the weird
thing
about old binky that's why she likes
spooky stuff
so you're not you don't believe in any
of this bull honky but
i've always okay i've always had a weird
feeling about myself this is gonna scare
people
i've always had a weird feeling about
myself i couldn't tell if this is
how i will die or how i died in a past
life
but i always know it was very violent
and not very good it was but i can't
tell if
i was also a bad person
you know what i mean like it's like very
hard to discern what the feeling is
but whenever i watch something
about someone being kidnapped or someone
being held
captive and not able to get out
like by someone else i get the weirdest
feeling it's like this
it's like nostalgia mixed with
urine and um
it's not it's something weird and so
i've always thought like that might
happen to me i can't tell what i'm
picking up and then
there's a thing in astrology get ready
buckle your seatbelt
called the north node and the north node
is the position of the north pole when
you're born
and that tells you two things because
there's it's a
it has two positions right so it tells
you
what happened to you in your past life
and what your purpose is
in this life and you know that you can
that's more hocus pocus to me like i
don't i'm like my purpose come on
but i was reading it my friend's really
into astrology i'm like north no the
[ __ ] is north node
and mine was like it was like
you were either a murderer
in a past life where you were murdered
in a past life and when it said that
and i've always felt this way and when
it said that it it really did freak me
out
so i'm choosing to feel like the thought
that
the feelings that i feel like oh am i
gonna be met with like an untimely end
in like a violent way i think they're
past life [ __ ] coming on but you have to
believe in that you have to believe in a
bunch of [ __ ] to feel that which i do
i'm reminded of a joke by
how neal feels super fan jimmy carr uh
timmy's gonna love this which is how do
you know
if your house is haunted it isn't
um none of it's don't i don't buy any of
it
i know i have a better whole hunch about
how i'm gonna i
whenever i think i'm gonna die
in a hospital i just then i go because i
think that i'm gonna get hit by a bus
it's gonna be whatever i think is gonna
happen that's not going to happen
sometimes in life
what i think is going to happen is
absolutely not going to happen and
sometimes in life
i have a complete premonition about
something hap
or or not like a feeling based on
yeah that'll probably happen you're kind
of
you're insightful like i feel like you
have i feel like when you feel like
psychic it's more like
just strong instincts it's it's pattern
recognition pattern recognition really
strong instincts like some people aren't
don't have a good like don't have a
close relationship with their instincts
you know they're like don't know what to
trust i don't know childhood [ __ ] who
knows
but i think it's more ju i think it
comes from growing up in an alcoholic
home
hyper vigilance yeah having to do a lot
of people
i think it can be expensive calculation
calculation and then
in terms of people and relationships
i've talked about that before just from
doing crowd work
you can tell i can tell who
someone is but they just deny it because
they're mad
yeah and you're calling them out and
they're embarrassing stuff and
so it's so much more psychology i mean
our brain is so
interesting that like we don't need to
make up
a bunch of hocus pocus it's like it's
brain it's
what your parents were like it's nature
and nurture it's not
the north node nature nurture and the
north node of course that's what
everybody hello i mean north node
scientists have debated
first note to me like i didn't know it
was a thing and then i was like no i
don't think i actually don't think it is
because
that just was like oh [ __ ] i was a
murderer like for a second
but then all the rest of the [ __ ] was
like didn't even
like it didn't even resonate with me so
just like it's funny how when we see
there's one thing and we make we like
sew the string together like
there's also the funny somebody made the
funny observation that
everyone was no was nobility in the
in in a former life like oh i was a
nobleman i was a queen i was a
it's the same where everyone were
african queens and kings and you're like
everyone would you were all kings who
was in the kingdom
right no i was no one was ever like yeah
i was a [ __ ]
i was a surf four lives in a row
[ __ ] surf because statistically it
would have been
i mean i did i think mate with going
i'm not like queen binky i'm like i
think i was a dirt bag in a past
life i like it and i knew i was a man i
think you're a dirt bike
right now do you know you're a man i
feel it i just feel it
i feel like you're and i feel like you
might have been a woman
i have some feminine quality yeah cool
great talking i'm in love with you
um okay name three things you and your
partner appear
to have in common partner thank you hi
partner we're sitting down
i'm just joking uh i think we have
similar values
in terms of
i think i'm more ambitious than you
i think we have similar values in some
ways and then i think there are ways
where i'm more
ambitious and let my ego
completely like no i'm not [ __ ] we
gotta [ __ ] get a set and we gotta do
it
no lights and i'm bringing ken over
and curtains and it's by the way we know
the wide still doesn't work trust me
um you know but uh but
so i think we have similar values in
that regard
i think we have similar sense of humor
yeah
and i think we like each other
like pretty naturally i like you like
you're likeable
thank you you're meaning you appea
you're you're um
appealing looking okay
and vibration but it's not even hot it's
like you just
look friendly oh yeah
uh like an animal would think you're
friendly
like oh that's like soft cheek just [ __ ]
like oh
whatever why you like me
i don't know like in that regular
because i don't everyone i mean i do
the last since i started the fat fat
program but
why you like me is the the reason you
like me i think
people wouldn't guess yeah i think
people i think we're like a
there's a show i watch called unlikely
animal friends
and i thought it's such a
how is that a show that's the name
but how do they find enough how many
couples are there i
there's like seasons i watch all of them
is it a different
it's always a different elephant and a
dog
[ __ ] there's no
there's a horse and a dog as well
somebody by the way
pitched me a great megan stallion joke
did i don't want to hear it
i don't think i used but um she said
uh she was a fan of the whole run and
said
that uh was a woman yeah was she white
i don't know uh she thought i
may or maybe i did the joke i can't
believe it that tory lanez
the relationship works because tory
lanez is the size of a jockey
so that's a [ __ ] good joke yeah it's
not about megan no it's about
it's about him yeah it's about the
shooter yeah [ __ ] active shooter did
you see the
did you see that that famous video where
he's the same size
sitting down and standing up yeah that's
i'm sorry
tori lanez who makes me cry yeah story
one
yes every time i think about that is
so funny um i
like you
because oh my unlikely animal friends
yes that's kind of what i feel like we
are
it's also a very good show but i feel
like
people look at us like unlikely animals
yes
you know yes but i feel like we
so i think we have a very similar
we have a very similar [ __ ] meter
mm-hmm
you're more aggressive about it but
having them give it up giving them up
having a similar [ __ ] meter
actually bonds you so much more because
it's like you're like yeah
what just forever like
you know that sort of phase but i like
you because
you're no
[Music]
no frills it's you this is it there's no
like secretive
oh and now the real neil yeah here's the
real neil
and you're really you're
so much easier to hang out with than
i think people would ever think you're
so easy and no
low maintenance almost no maintenance
yeah no maintenance
way more giving than anybody gives you
credit for
you're so giving but you do it with this
like face
like it's just like i don't know just
take it this is yeah it doesn't feel
like there's
the lyrics where i [ __ ] gave you
shoot whatever the lyrics i
[ __ ] hear yeah but i'm not
no that's the thing though in the future
you're never it's all facebook you're
never him i don't know how they got how
do they get
the guys came to install curtains the
guy's like that's supposed to be you
pretty great that's so funny yeah um
no you're but your giving is like
i don't know you want it stay up yeah i
don't know yeah and it'll be like piles
of cash
yeah really thank you
so you're very
i feel like your personality is actually
very sweet nice
and like easy no drama
this is the most dramatic you ever are
this is like you're being on the show
on the show you're not you're right
you're actually right
you're never this you're just so chill
and relaxed like
oh yeah i don't know you need yeah like
so easy
you need a snack you want water do you
want shoes take my lamp like
yeah you're gonna will a globe yeah will
took a globe he pledged well that's nice
so um you're actually also appealing
personality wise that no one gives you
credit for yeah well that
yes look i'm nice i have a lot of hype
and his friends in my life
i don't actively want to be around
someone who's an [ __ ]
or who's just like disagreeable or like
not
like so you know it it on the show it
looks way more like i'm like
and you're just like but off camera i'm
like yeah and you're like girl
no uh but yeah no i think you nailed it
though and we like documentaries
that's a good bond some people really
don't like money
in comedy and we know the same people
and we have a lot of similar events um
yeah i don't think anyone i don't think
i think people that know me know me
five times better than people that don't
know me meaning
there are i i bet if you took a poll
oh yeah and said to just took black
people and said
why do black men like neil brennan
70 of them would be i have no [ __ ]
idea
crickets like i have no i don't [ __ ]
this guy
i don't understand it or
whatever and anyone any why does why do
why whatever any nice any these people
don't understand mullany
yeah like what anybody why would they i
and because i'm
helpful you're really interesting you're
helpful and interesting yeah
i mean again it's not but guys in a
month you're going to be like
i used to watch a podcast called how
neophil this seems different
this guy's a charismatic it's coming um
good question number nine we're only on
number nine this might be a two-parter
yeah this might be
two but i don't mind it's fun it's funny
right
uh for what in your life do you feel
most grateful
your your watch that ellen gave you
i honestly it sounds
so cheesy but being alive
just i there's so many you know i always
feel like
when someone dies we feel bad for like
uh their family like oh my i'm so
sorry it's like that guy died like feel
bad for him or her
i yeah i always feel yeah we feel bad i
feel bad
i feel yeah it was the jeffrey epstein
thing it's like he
died well i didn't get justice he's
dead he's it's over that's
pretty good i mean you're dead he gave
himself the death penalty
you're changing my point jeffrey epstein
yes you were talking about jeffrey i'm
so grateful for him
uh i yeah i don't know i just feel like
sometimes i look at life as you know
we're all
it's just this trajectory you know and
some people
just get taken out of the race like some
people are taken out of the directory
and we get to keep going and
somebody yesterday died a terrible death
i'm sure
and you know you ate fruit and i like
did laundry so i just think
um i'm not saying value all the time you
have that's important
it's impossible it's like appreciating
your health it just cannot be done
but just just take time to you don't
have to live every day like it's your
last you don't have to sit there and be
like thank you jesus
but i think you can take time to be like
you're still here
everybody else who's dead don't don't
even get to
pick up a nectarine and cut it or like
do a podcast or like think like should i
get
what should i ever do like they're
they're times done on this earth so i
just think
that's that's like you could be grateful
a lot of things
in it but you're you wouldn't be
grateful for those things if you didn't
have life so i i just think it's
um to be grateful for yeah i did a
i did stand up last night and in a
like whatever like a it's not legal and
um
and uh snitch y'all and
i was actually grateful i said i'm
really grateful to be here i guess you
know how oprah for years has been saying
be more grateful
yeah i was like i'm actually grateful to
be here i was like it'll pass
like don't worry it'll be gone soon that
i'm very grateful
for that i'm very grateful for being
funny
uh you funny and
i'm as i talk to
superfan jimmy carr
jj the level of
fortune i don't mean literal fortune
the level of good fortune that
just for instance he and i but really
any most people listening to this being
alive is [ __ ]
like you beat the odds and living in the
west or living any sort of is
in terms of life experience is like very
high
and then i i
i have ringside seats in for the world
i'm either sometimes i'm in the ring and
sometimes i'm
in the front row of
yeah the like the [ __ ] world
like the [ __ ] the people and the
things i've heard like things that
obama told trevor and trevor like just
[ __ ] where it's like oh okay
yeah like [ __ ] that's like jesus um
i'm very grateful i'm very grateful for
that
like the the the ringside seat but i'm
more than anything i'm grateful for how
i was able to
get it which is by being interesting and
by my my personality i'm grateful for my
personality which
by the way a lot about
as we've enumerated on this show but i
am
i'm grateful for the good parts of my
personality
yeah that's probably the best the best
the
the my the thing i'm most grateful for
and that's my answer for number
nine okay number ten
[Music]
i'm actually gonna do good if you could
change anything about the way you were
raised
what would it be
wow how much time we got anything about
the way i was raised
wouldn't you change a lot yeah i would
change yeah i would change
most most of us all next question okay
uh i would change
i wish there was more love in the house
i wish there was more
i wish there was more there was the
weird
christian catholic thing but that was
more about
rules and regulations which you love but
have i ever showed you the
the rules that my mom
had hold on i got it framed
and laminated all right so these are my
mom's
general rules from probably 1984.
so these are the general rules from my
catholicism yes handmade handwritten
uh so on one side the rules other side
disciplinary action
right there it's basically disciplinary
action it's a prison
it's present it's so [ __ ] up number
one and
my mom's my mom's basically nice she's
just
so catholic and spare the rod spoiled
the child and
prided cometh before the fault just all
these [ __ ] crazy maxims
talk about old man phrases that's why
that bible's got a few
no tv on school nights okay all right
fine
uh one hour of tv in the afternoon
what do you mean in the afternoon you
get an hour and for school nights
even afternoon
one hour after sundown no tb okay
uh disciplinary action is no tv the next
day if you go over
um this is they're they're pretty
reasonable two hours of tv
total for the weekend
and you gotta notify her which ones
which ones what
which what you want to watch wow
and uh disciplinary action no tv next
weekend
so um
but again we had one tv and there's
[ __ ] nine people oh that actually
i mean it makes sense but it was more
about the morality of the show
but could you watch tv while someone
else was watching tv
or you just got to determine yes you
could if it was yours
if you we both watched dallas family
ties
you wanted to watch family ties so you
watched that and then it's someone
else's turn
but why i couldn't pay you back no you
couldn't draft off of somebody else's
so you had to leave the room yeah yeah
you did
what it was counted against your time
no wonder you want to watch tv the next
weekend wow i'm learning so much keep
going
take a walk this was this is one of the
great ones existing laundry rooms
which we all knew apparently neither the
washer nor the dryer is to be used in
the morning
which i don't understand why not seems
like the best time to use that
yeah here are the wrong laundry rules
okay by the way the disciplinary action
one dollar fine
this is explaining so much i know
i could go here were the rules and this
this leads into another story i'm sorry
i'm monopolizing it but no no this is
so interesting
if you did laundry we we
all did our own laundry starting
probably age nine
if you did if your laundry was in
the washer and
you weren't on top of it when the cycle
was done
and you didn't put it in the dryer
because there was just all this anger
and catholic rural spare the round [ __ ]
people wouldn't put it in the dryer for
you they would just put it wet on top of
the dryer
um just on some like no
you [ __ ] up i mean that one's like
yeah no
but that's just that was like the
culture right yeah
again that's what i'm talking about love
it's like i'm your brother yeah
like yeah but i you know what i'm
thinking of this reminds me of you know
that's like when i lived in dorms animal
friends no
this is not animal friends this is like
when you lived in
it's like i always say it's like a it
was like a group hump
damn somewhat again group homes are
awful but
um so okay so
if you so then if you left
let's say you put it in the dryer and
uh didn't collect it from the dryer
it would then be put on top of the dryer
okay like you're just dumped half the
time we get behind the you know what i
mean then you gotta climb
like a sock if it stayed on the dryer
for too long
there was a laundry chute my mom would
throw it down the laundry chute into the
basement
just like cold concrete your dirt your
clean clothes are now dirty and
if they stayed in the bottom of the
laundry chute for too long
confiscated you're closed yes
so would you one year you're gonna think
i'm making this up and
who you met one year for christmas
and got a box of her old clothes back
that was what she got and also she lived
on the
because there's so many of us we did
three story house and got
a uh fire ladder
for out her window and
a box of her old clothes like in case
there was a fire yeah
like a true value home depot
throw a fire ladder out your window and
climb down
she got that and a box of old clothes
and i remember she called one of her
friends
and her friend had gotten a bmw
wow yes that's again that's one
that's plus and now you can't use it in
the morning
because things weren't draconian enough
seriously
okay a one dollar fine which back then
was a lot of money
sandwiches are to be made for the week
on saturday or sunday for your life all
your sandwiches
for the week make them friday bad
put them in the freezer
and then every day you would take one
out for lunch
for your to go was it delicious what do
you think bankianka
binkyanka what do you think do you think
it was delicious
here's the thing that you think it's not
a matter of
uh you think it's a matter of
deliciousness this thing you're not
thinking of
hey can a sandwich automatically defrost
between eight a.m and now
bianca can it no
so you would end up using you wouldn't
eat the frozen bar you just eat the
out the outer rim this is awful
it's not so nice um and
the disciplinary action in quotes not
kidding
starvation
will push in on it
we have to underline it all right next
one shoes
and books in slot or room there was i
think we had
yeah like little slop like so many of us
so and if you and uh the disciplinary
action she couldn't figure it out like
you with the harlem renaissance
uh discretionary that's what she said
tbd
tvd playing by here how am i feeling i'm
gonna feel that like
jazz um
chores to be finished
there was a schedule of chores every
saturday like
vacuum the front steps and the back
steps sweep out this
the gutters whatever kitchen deep what
you had to have them done on saturday
before noon
and if you didn't the next week you had
to do everyone else's chores
ooh so when people [ __ ] up yeah
everybody was happy
was everybody like no yeah i got next
week off
thank you dirtbag did that happen
yeah how good was everybody at following
the rules
uh
pretty good this and there's a note
under do everyone's work the following
saturday
that goes for everybody regardless of
where you have to go
no exceptions really i'm your kid i'm
your child
wow no exceptions this is so [ __ ] i
know it's kind
of [ __ ] up and kind of not no it's
this makes me sad because like okay
what year is this 70 no 70 85
oh yeah um homework
8 pm started no phone calls after 8 pm
that's the thing that people don't
remember is the landline
well that there was like strict rules
like
no one called each other after no
because it would wake up the laws yeah
we couldn't get if you got a phone call
between seven and eight
it's not on here but if you got a call
during dinner
i think you weren't allowed to you
weren't allowed to
use the phone meanwhile it's an incoming
call i had nothing to do with it no
exceptions
no quarter given i'm surprised no one
ran away
oh do you think norah didn't try to run
away i would you know
i was like um okay
uh please leave for church because again
you can't forget
this is all about church and the lord
10 minutes before church you got to get
there well what do you mean
she's taking you to church no i mean
sometimes but there were so many of us
like there'd be different i'm going to
go to the 10 o'clock or whatever
um and if you don't leave 10 minutes
before no tv or telephone
uh for or or and you're grounded for a
week
or as you call it or out for a week
um do all daily chores on schedule
punishment do everyone's the next day
if you don't do it and finally
the very prisony no food or drink to
leave the kitchen
disciplinary action jazz
we'll feel it out i don't get it so you
just can't you can't you ha
you can't bring food to the basement you
can't bring food to your room
a drink something must have happened
or maybe or not there was a lot of work
furious people
i get it but also you know what don't
have [ __ ] nine kids
sorry it's gonna come with they were
they were
they were too many if you're yeah it's
just too many it's too many
it would i don't there's none that i
want to sacrifice specifically like man
did we need him
um i think he seemed a little
superfluous isn't he he's a little
redundant though
did we need um but this is this is
[ __ ] crazy i mean it's just so this
isn't even so much about
the church or it's just about my dad's
one of 13
alcoholic dad abusive mother didn't love
him
said i don't love you tried to give my
dad away
oh he was test they a
family came to like take my dad for a
spin
and they brought him back and it wasn't
a match
wow it's just not that into you dad yeah
uh starring my dad and uh jennifer
what's your name
um uh no the girl that was this
whitney's friend
oh yeah anderson no not addison but
jennifer or whatever
i know but someone i'm just not of an
indian the one the main one
anyhow um so this isn't even don't put
this on the church this is just my
parents
anger i know but there's so many and a
lot of people like what do you do it's
like what i said about china i get
a lot of people regulating but like
there's something extra in those
there's something uh there's something
extra
[ __ ] up yeah i get like yeah it's a
little
it's a little like try me turn the knife
it's kind of police brutality
it's just like why you wonder why black
guys like me something
it's a little like because [ __ ] up [ __ ]
up one degree
and i'm gonna have you i wish you would
not freeze your sandwiches
oh [ __ ] oh scarf so
sterile about it it's loveless yeah for
real did they ever like hug you and say
we love you neil you little baby
i would sit on my mom's lap after dinner
oh cute
that's nice uh
but did you ever sit on your dad's lap
or hug him a little did you hug him but
after a certain age i was like oh you're
a [ __ ] [ __ ]
like nine ten i was like [ __ ] this guy
he was mean to you
nine eight nine yeah yeah yeah
i just you know yeah it's just like you
see
you see that and you go oh i don't know
how you're gonna be uh
how lucky you're gonna be in romance
there buddy they just didn't
it's like it doesn't set you up well it
sets you up well for
discipline yeah like accomplishments or
a three-story house you're rich
um so it's really like it's good for
that but i don't know if it's
good for connecting with people even
though you connect with a lot of people
you're there's parts of you that are
difficult just there's parts of
everybody that are difficult everybody
has difficult parts but
maybe yours clash when it comes to like
sharing
your like mind body soul space like
life with someone it's harsh it's what
it is
it's harsh to it's harsh for children i
don't think kids shouldn't have rules
but no
and the reasons are sundry
but they are uh but it's just like
okay okay so we're just gonna
like just this is the weird thing is
you know we don't have kids and you
think about like i wonder why
but you think about when you have a kid
it's like like a little baby
like you know at some point they didn't
know what a having a kid would feel like
and then it falls into this just like
tolerating
these kids just like all right we gotta
do this
no training no like why have so many
kids
because they weren't allowed to use
birth control because of the bible
i feel like they could because of the
2000 year old book
um okay well mine
[Laughter]
yeah two an hour later too much spicy
food
no mine is easy i wish my parents would
have spoke their
native language to be more because my
farsi
and my spanish is it's like it's choppy
my
grammar's weird but i was i i was in for
i was in persian school and i've
taken spanish a lot but it's still like
it's just
better when it comes from your parents
like they yell at me
so i know how to yell at someone in all
these languages but
i can take if you're speaking you only
know farsi it's
you you're only speaking when triggered
uh no i and it's and only my grandmas
really speak to me so
and my grandmas think i'm great so i'm
always like telling them like oh correct
me
and they're like no everything's perfect
like no
grandma granny don't
two weeks of granny barcelona um
okay take four minutes
and tell your partner your life story in
as much detail as possible it ain't
gonna happen in four minutes
also i have a podcast you should listen
to them uh and if you haven't
seen it um number 12 if you could wake
up tomorrow having gained
any one quality or ability what would it
be
mine would be um i think
and i hate to blame it on a thing but
there's some part of i think my adhd
that
my it's i'm really motivated i have a
lot of energy but it's really hard to
focus and um
i procrastinate a lot so i wish i could
just channel a lot of my energy
into being bet being more diligent at
getting to work once i'm work
once i have to really force myself and
once i do i'm fine but that
hump of like it's perceived as laziness
um but it really is hard for people
that with adhd to like get
to it there's a good book i didn't read
it mike gibbons read it
and that's as good as me reading it i'm
kidding mike uh mike gibbons comedy
writer
and does a podcast with um fitzsimmons
uh
oh yeah he does he has a few yeah um
that procrastination is basically
you are fear you have a fear of
failure and fear of imperfection and so
you've got this fear of imperfection
that's kind of crippling you and then at
a certain point the
fear of being a someone who didn't do
the thing just overtakes it
so you have to do it i'm not gonna lie i
really
i absolutely don't have a fear of being
imperfect like i don't
i've i'm like good enough great like i
don't have this
it's something i've noticed compared to
my friends like i have friends that are
like it has to be perfect
and i'm just like it's fine you're like
what are you crazy it's not fine
i'm like dude relax it'll be fine like i
don't have
that fear in my brain it's
not a it's that i want to try i'll be
sitting at my computer it's like okay
do it and my focus just goes
like to okay i'm gonna it's almost like
when i have time to do it
i wanna do other things because then i'm
like let me get these all out the way so
i can just
focus and then like cut to three hours
later i'm like
[ __ ] i i'm not focusing it's a real
straight-up focus and then whenever i
take
when i was younger i took ritalin i put
myself on it i read an article and i was
like
i think i have 80d you know what i'm
going to contact the people in europe
and get some ritalin
how did you put yourself on it i just
wrote i read an article about
yeah but that a lot of people read a lot
of articles i know i'm gonna tell you so
i read an article when i was like 16
in like i don't know times or something
and
i i was like this over prescription of
america sort of
i'm like oh and then they talk about 80d
magazine like i think i always think i
have that because i was the most
distracting kid
always cracking jokes passing notes like
could not focus
and i was like let me try this [ __ ] and
so i don't know i just made a call to my
doctor and i was like gave
uh just psychiatrist no therapist
psychiatrist
psychiatrist you just said i think i
have this i just thought a hunch
and then she gave me an interview she's
like sure and i just knew it'd be easy
to
get after reading that article and then
my grades went from like c's to
straight a's interesting it was weird
and because i was underage
they i they make you
take a like take a questionnaire for
your uh teachers
about like monitoring my behavior and it
was all
like for children because mostly it's
not usually diagnosed in your teen so
it was like um plays well with others
shares toys
i was like this is so funny but my sex
toys at this age
16. so yeah because there's just
pediatricians
lighters doesn't give them back
so my grades were so drastically
changed that i was like oh this [ __ ]
dumb yellow pill
is literally like it unlocked everything
that's when i realized
okay i have to focus um but it really
did
create i think neuropathy in my brain
because then i stopped needing it as
much
even though i use it now sometimes when
i really need to focus
um i think you can also learn [ __ ] but
it's focusing i have a huge focusing
issue
yeah i wish i was more pleasant as we've
discussed
and i yeah i just wish i was
i wish i was i had a sunnier disposition
i have a question about your sunny
disposition i have a
can i doctor feel you please does your
so let's say someone does something it's
totally innocuous but for some reason
it's like
makes you want to be like you know
does that come from i feel like it comes
from a place of
are you annoyed or is it anxiety of just
like i don't know what they want me to
do
and so it's it's what it feels like what
it is is
i deal with it with will i deal with it
with i was doing a i'm
for the documentary uh
with somebody i made fun of called
captain car accidents
no one had a problem with it right um
fine
on his broke his back kevyn hart right
work together friend of mine
but so i was making a deck and uh for
and so and i had to just
i needed i needed to be good and i
needed it to be
what i what it how it would look fun and
interesting and compelling
and i couldn't get it took like eight
versions back and forth back and then i
go
what i did it with you will where i'm
like what can i do
to get you to do this what can i do so
i'm i worry that i i feel sorry for
myself
cause i'm like you can't [ __ ] nobody
cares hmm
like i sound like trump yeah um
nobody cares but me uh
i don't know how to get what i need from
people
and i'm gonna look bad because of it
but you're so quick to
i feel like a lot of it can be explained
with
just people don't always understand and
comprehend even when they do people
you'll be like hey can you do this for
me oh you want me to do that like
not everybody communication wise i know
and that's
i i don't know if anybody watched the
david blaine
balloon special yesterday it was on
youtube what no i missed the
[ __ ]
30 28 000 feet on i mean
it's holding one balloon no it's a bunch
of balloons and he's actually harnessed
it but it's
[ __ ] crazy insane okay
nothing below nothing
the amount of miscommunication in
a life or death scenario was making me
you couldn't believe who was [ __ ]
him and the like the eight
assistant director or the guy you can't
even
the guy kept going the the main guy it
was so crazy
before he's on the ground so he's got
basically weights on him
um right sandbags five pound sandbags
and um and the and so
he they're trying to figure out like
he's and
the main guy white-haired guy goes yeah
we need five pounds when he he keeps
saying we need five pounds
and so they're like oh so all right so
here's the five pound weight you asked
for
and he goes no i mean a five pound
balloon
what oh what which is like what the [ __ ]
is a fire and the guy goes
oh i thought you kept saying five pounds
so i thought you meant
wait which of course you would like that
not a fight
the guy the white haired guy goes well
i'm sorry you misunderstood
and it was but that was the beginning of
like oh
and then david blaine's like released so
he's [ __ ]
8 000 feet up in the air and he goes
should i release the uh a weight and
they go
uh dave we're gonna have you hold off on
that
and then okay fine whatever and then
he's like okay
and then uh like 30 seconds later they
go so david
you released that weight right and he's
like no you just [ __ ]
and you can see david blaine if i were
him i would have snapped and gone fellas
i'm gonna [ __ ] die oh my god
you don't if this doesn't if you don't
get your [ __ ] right and i
promise you there were a dozen of them
and this
calm [ __ ] was like he actually
said at one point like you guys are the
best crew i've ever worked with
yeah and it's like dude yeah well you
have to look oh my god that's so funny
yeah i love it his shit's not even magic
it's just like i'm gonna do this it's a
stunt but i gotta say it
moved me for some reason it like he does
[ __ ] that yeah
it moved me yeah i can't explain it it's
great it's but it's mostly great for the
you would have freaked out though
the community i would have been like yo
mother i've yelled it at aed's before
you're an assistant director assist me
[ __ ] i'm
begging you i'm begging you but the
problem
is that rules i love them
you love them but the problem is that
you know
there's saying
things they're saying what you want and
then there's being an effective
communicator
and maybe you're not an effective
communicator
but you are being as clear as you can be
you know what i mean yeah i mean in
terms of like work stuff
i think you're actually very clear
outside
well you could speak to this better than
i can but
but i think i'm clear and what i would
argue
is that people just ha
see no no that no no no no no that is
will nothing
i've told you like hey dude and then you
go oh
this is like ah but neil failed like
have a list
of things but the thing is you
you also do have a tendency to take it
as
a personal person absolutely
unless it's that one like i feel like
when you were younger like that guy on
the movie
like that was just like man [ __ ] these
people [ __ ] this guy
[ __ ] but like it's never personal
it can be do you think being late is
personal i don't think being late it's
personal i have a problem with being
late so i
think it's inconsiderate behavior so i
try
really hard to work on it and but i
think it's
because i find that i'm late for some
people and right on time for others
the only time i'm that like i if i
take it as a job with consequences i'm
on time if it's
my friends i'm not on time and that's
just it it's not because i don't value
my friendships it's
because i'm scared to be late i'm scared
to be late
for a job like here or when i go to work
i'm never late
and it's so funny because everyone's
like
well not never but i can i communicate
when i'm late oh yeah i've never known
you i've never you've never no showed
no no you've never liked that i just
stroll in like when i'm gonna be late i
try to tell you because i'm like you
can't look you can't win them all
but you can't be inconsiderate
and for a long time i was so scared
because of my time management skills i
just wouldn't address it
and that's so much worse you know what i
mean uh it's like
take it take it just be like hey i'm so
sorry for being late boom
you know what i mean i think that like
i don't take the lateness personal with
you
but i do i there are times where i could
feel myself starting to take it
personally
i'm not late here that often though i'd
say you're late
i'd say you're late no more than 10
minutes every week
but between but around 10 minutes every
week
roughly you look at your text because
you tell me no i know but
the funny thing is and that's so funny
and i always thought this i'm like
i tell him when i'm gonna be late and i
always have this thought that like
because you don't you're not always good
with memory you're good with like
impressions of things
and so because i tell you i feel like
you have an impression that i'm late a
lot but i'm not late a lot
i'm actually not i like i know i'm not
we're gonna we're i'm not gonna go
through the text now but
we'll go over the last ten weeks of time
that's it and will
and you could do your google locations
as well i'd appreciate it
i would say the last 10 weeks you've
been late more than five times no
no right i'm actually no no no just stop
relax
i got rules i know i'm like no but
this is i wish i was not like this
i i i wish i didn't i wish i wasn't like
this
but which is why i'm reading the books
and the
i there's a podcast called against the
rules that michael lewis does
and there's a thing about um performance
coaches
and i'm like i think i got to go to a
pro i think i got to go to a performance
coach because i get
good with a new
system like i can in ingest it and
put it into but on its feet but this is
the
issue so let's just take the late thing
as an example i would say
of the times i come here 90
of the time you're not ready i so it's
like
right you're almost never ready
so when we say i'm we're talking about
three to five minutes late me coming
here i walk in you're either
not in the shower uh making food
on a phone call like we are all on we
are all
waiting on you most of the time
no no it's not it's it's the truth so
what i mean
is that it's funny that when we talk
about it
it's bianca you're five minutes late to
a thing i'm going to be ready for in 45
minutes so
there is a disconnect of um what have
you were late
i would but i was i was asleep that i
was i'm still being a bad boy
i was i would argue that i'm not
if i'm late it's me and him are setting
up the lights no
that's recently we have been doing this
podcast when they were just set up
this is only the last few episodes i'm
talking about the whole time
and that's okay but i'm just saying
there is a personal you take it personal
when someone's late but when i come
and you're not ready for like an hour or
45 minutes
and i've budgeted okay this is gonna
take this time oh okay now it's gonna
take this time and i adjust everything i
don't
actually take it i only made fruit today
because i thought he was still working
i'm just saying that it's there's you
take it too personal when like
you do exhibit the same behavior and
then i don't think anyone takes it
personal the other way
yeah i gotta i get a bad personality
i like your personality no i know it's
but it's got it's got a tissue
okay um number 13 if a crystal ball
could tell you the truth about yourself
your life the future or anything else
what would you want to know i think
cristobal just did tell me about myself
um
what would i want to know i don't know
because that's the older i get
the more i realize that
i things
work out almost always not
because i have ringside seats i just
mean they did
you can figure it out nothing is as bad
in
actuality as it is in theory right and
whether it's bad or
good it's the good the thing that you
dream of being amazing is like
pretty good and the thing that you dream
about being
horrible is not that survivable
um so
i don't know i just i all my in terms of
the future i just hope i live
forever yeah i do not want to live
forever
just get people in line i just gotta
i would not continue to bring the hammer
down it's funny when
you're when i was younger you want to
know so much but yeah like when you're a
kid
like i played with ouija board bad idea
um
now you're you don't even pay attention
to astrology or anything no way
north node um but
i think now i don't want to know because
it then it's just like i'm not even that
far away from it so i'm just
i'm working towards something i might
not get or like oh someone's gonna
like it's like i don't want to know all
that i think i just want to
like tell me who to watch out for or
what to watch out for or tell me like
give me a warning that i can avoid
that's what i would like to know
yeah i mean i in yeah i know what you
mean run [ __ ] would be like dude
neil if you have an opportunity you want
a black audience at a horror movie what
you want
[ __ ] no i want a black audience in a
horror movie
for your life yeah for my life
that's so funny it would be like
remember dream on
on hbo they had they would it was a guy
and then they would
show his thoughts and they would you cut
in old movies
no uh-huh yeah it was one of those hbo
shows from the 83 like
is this good right um but
tim hurley who's one of the best comedy
writers
uh who wrote on snl he went to college
with sandler and then wrote edison out
with him and he wrote happy gilmore and
billy madison and all the other
like probably 10 sailor movies um
hat wrote a pitch to sketch snl where
uh i don't know i guess it was the guy
from dream on was the host
and he kept thinking a thought but the
thought he kept thinking
was um jack nicholson axing scat man
crothers in the back of that
so it's just from the shining so it's
just a regular scene and he keeps
uh but a black audience in your head
would be such a funny thing that's so
funny
uh yeah i don't know what i'd want to
know
i just i just know for the most part
things have been okay
things have worked out okay and i if
it's
i don't want to know if i'm going to be
a paraplegic or something
like i don't have meaning
you realize a lot of it's not helpful
it's just not gonna make a difference
like neil you're gonna and
you couldn't if somebody told me how my
life was gonna turn out
or like the last 15 years what it turned
out
i would have been i would have been like
oh
i'm glad the way it turned out but it's
not it's not it's very non-linear
and not you know
then there's yeah so i don't know what i
would want to know no i kind of nothing
just let me see what happens but you're
right in that the older you get the more
you're just like
i don't want to know let me just see
what happens
wrong [ __ ] okay 14. is there something
that you've dreamed of doing for a long
time why haven't you done it
skydiving i thought about scott i
haven't watched the david blaine thing
what i realized is you would not like it
i don't know if i wouldn't i might like
it but i had the realization do
watching the david blaine thing is
there are people that like skydiving and
there are people that like
doing psychedelic drugs
and those are my skydiving they probably
coincide i don't know i but it seems
like they're
they there's not a big venn diagram of
people that
i'm gonna do ayahuasca next month and
i'm excited about that i really want to
i keep meeting people that are like
ayahuasca petty mother drug father i'm
like
yeah like i yeah it's like anything the
the culture around it's him
i went on a date with a guy and he was
like oh so you do i was like it's called
ceremony um we go to ceremony and i was
like
okay cool then he talked about some
other drug called
rape but it's like dropping that's right
you're talking about a hell of a drug
rape's a hell of a drug i think it's
rapey rock rape
uh rape it's like
rape drug but not rape not the rape drug
but rubies
no ruthenol rappa
rape is that what it's called yeah it's
like nicotine oh you got to be 18 to
even look at it
so you know it's hot rapa did he agree
but it's not it's like some sort of drug
yeah like a and i was like oh yeah that
drug what do you
wrap a drug and he was like it's an
herbal medicine like i
i don't like this how many times you
[ __ ] this is every girl's story about
dating like he's the where anyway we're
going out again
absolutely not no to me i was just like
dude i don't like i don't like being
in a museum when i talk like don't touch
the artwork like i don't know
stop correcting me i just met you
ceremony and then i was just like if
everything is this serious
yeah i i don't like that you know what i
mean like i don't like when it's like
you don't want to be a like why are you
talking like this
just why are you talking you don't if
you don't have to talk like this why are
you talking like right
this is like landmark some [ __ ] cult
[ __ ] so
that i wish it was just cooler sounding
everybody's right good luck um
ayahuasca i've heard some people have
done it and it's been fine
and then other people have done it it's
like changed their life yeah
so i don't i get the feeling i
i did ibogaine two years ago or three
years ago
uh which is a which is real in the
family
and i puked and did all that stuff and
it was fine it was all right
but this i mean ayahuasca i think is
more
likely i think it really does there's a
guide and it's like a
guide in the drug yeah um so i'm gonna
do it
it's good for ptsd it's good for people
with rules
go with the yellowed rules
no ayahuasca uh penalty uh what have you
done what have you what do you want to
do
that you haven't done oh don't know
sell my [ __ ] show that i've written
i'm working on it but i would
that would make me really happy um
i don't like the term make me happy why
because i don't think it would and
accomplish clean enjoyment i don't know
but like you'd feel proud of it but make
me
like from that day on no i mean i think
for me
i think one it's hard to do that to
uh i i just would
you know when you think something's good
and you think it's a good idea
and sometimes you never get it confirmed
and she's like
that was i can't relate to that at all
are you always like i had the greatest
idea you know people have those yeah i
had the greatest idea for this
or like i had the greatest idea for a
blank yep and so
someone buys your [ __ ] it's like sanity
yeah it's a little bit closer validating
uh 15. what is the greatest
accomplishment
of your life you go mr three-story house
probably my three-story house uh
no i don't i don't even in terms of
uh money i don't feel
any connection to a house
i don't feel like i own my property i
don't
i've talked about it before like i don't
have anything especially valuable in my
house
i don't computer tv probably
my tv at this point i've had it for two
years probably worth 180 bucks
yeah so people are like locking and it's
like what do you
the shrimp this of course my giant
shrimp my giant popeye shrimp
um love that chicken from powham
louisiana louisiana yeah that's
that was mine um my a cop
mine would be a tie
between chappelle show oh yeah and
three mics and the
um and it would be a tie between
and but the older i get the more i
am would go with three mics because
i no one believes i did chamel show
and um
it's more impressive to go from
a tv writer and producer
to become a comedian comedian with like
[ __ ] on netflix like it's kind that's
kind of like on
whether anyone realizes or not it's kind
of on
it's no one does that no one's done it
no one if you don't if you don't
a lot of people know a lot about comedy
but they don't get
the just the pro like the progression of
a comedian's life and yeah almost no one
does what you've done
yeah and everybody made fun of me like
you [ __ ] like brett aren't said i'm
memento cause i'm doing my career
backwards one of the great slams all
that's hilarious
it's true um uh
but yeah like that is
like a that's a cool thing that's a
[ __ ] cool thing
to have done and so i'm proud and it was
like
emotional too and whatever and the the
it was uh innovative like as a format
yeah
so and that is
dear class of 2020.
um my greatest accomplishment i don't
know
i feel like it doesn't have to be like
career
no no i'm not even thinking that i'm
just thinking um
up until this point
i think it's not like
one thing i could say but i feel like i
have
picked up my life and dumped it in a
country where i don't speak the language
multiple times and well when you're
when you commit identity fraud that's
something you have to do
pretty often and um
[Music]
it that for me it's
it's like and being able to thrive
in meet friends get a job
learn the language and i just that to me
is really hard to do
especially doing it in your like late
teens and then
20s and as a woman too yeah making
girlfriends guy friends
but also like it's you know there's
traveling as a woman is different than
traveling as a man right and being
i've been in some really crazy
situations in really weird parts of the
world
and i've always been able to just like
rely on myself
and um so
it's like i spent a lot of the first
part of my like adult life
traveling never being in the same place
for more than like eight months
dropping my [ __ ] not knowing anybody
leaving a year later with like a huge
friend group and a community and i've
done it so many times
that i just feel like you know people
don't do that it's weird that you
ghost the friend groups every single
time
what a choice do you have there's people
who in america that's like have never
left their
[ __ ] blocks yeah so so that to me i
feel like
that has set me up so i feel like that's
an accomplishment but
that is an accomplishment i'm just kind
of riffing like i don't know i haven't
if i i'm sure when i leave i'll be like
but
voice send a voice send well a voice
over uh and just happen
to put it over a voice message
i would also like to say i
think i'm proud of is i do i have stuck
to my guns
into our earlier point a lot of the guns
jam and blow up in my face
but some of them are good
guns about convictions
my personal convictions or suspicions
about like i think i could do that or
or or like i don't know something there
yeah um is i'm like
that about myself and that i'm proud of
that
i don't really do anything the right way
yeah and it
turns out okay number 16
i would like to say for the record this
is great i don't think i'm falling in
love with you
but i like you more oh really yes i like
you more
now that but here's another thing that's
suspicious about human beings is
this is all our point of view so we're
probably wrong
about a lot of what we think i mean i
say like
if you want to play the i'll say i said
it before and i'll say it again
um there's no worse source of
information about someone than
themselves
i disagree because i have a really good
memory
and i no i'm talking about shading no no
i'm saying listen
i'm saying that i learned so much about
people
people tell on themselves when they
don't realize yeah yeah
well you mean what i mean is i'm
saying all these things and with no
uh self-awareness i mean i'm the
uh you could
you could watch this and go look at this
[ __ ] white [ __ ] rich
[ __ ] ringside seat having
[ __ ] dude
you could look at it that way or you
could look at it as like oh yeah grabs a
[ __ ]
kind of [ __ ] it really like that's right
i don't know which is true
is the point well i i have my the one i
you know which one i want to believe
of course but the nice thing is most
people listen to this podcast i think
we've created a culture that they they
feel like where they know us kind of
so i feel like everyone for the most
part is listening to this and not
not hate listening hopefully and not
just being like oh that [ __ ] meal of
course you do it's just like listen you
know we're just like
people so many car accidents rage people
driving in oncoming traffic
over my jokes about stuff um
what do you value most in a friendship
i know what you value most attention uh
loyalty and
be funny and interesting yeah you've
said it loyalty for
sure yeah loyalty and be funny and
interesting and real loyalty and
meaning even if it
hurts you or or
not i'm not saying like you got a
[ __ ] ride i'm just saying
you know i don't i just it's really hard
to know what someone's code is
at the beginning of a relationship
there's no way to find out
there's no seal buds
class there's no orientation there's no
hell week there's no whatever um
so you don't know until you're and and
i have friends that have been really
that have exceeded them
and my expectations or but not many
and you're not gonna believe this i take
it personally
mine is
i don't know i think i have weirdly a
low bar for
in terms of behavior like i have a lot
of high maintenance friends
and a lot of low maintenance friends so
that's i'm all over the place but
i don't i just think there's like an
instinct that you can
sense that they i don't a [ __ ] i don't
know how to answer this
what do you yeah no there there's like
yes there's there's a vibration
where it's like oh i know we're at least
like this is we're at this baseline we
meet on this one
like i can't like if you're like i don't
know
i don't know how to say what i'm not
into but
everybody i meet is also not into that
like you're not a [ __ ] you're
giving you're cool yeah i have more
selfish friends than others but for the
most part
i don't know yeah there's just there's a
weird vibration that you just like click
up to yeah but also i mean just fun
like on some level just be fun does
nothing for me
fun uh no no but i would rather
if somebody said would you rather um
go hiking
would you rather go canoeing or whatever
a thing that people consider fun
would you rather go
the things i consider fun are are
worky yeah i like like
all my friends are in comedy so i would
rather would i rather
write a sketch with somebody or write a
joke with somebody
or hike with them i'd rather write a
joke a million times and there's no
not try it out right game it out a
million times i never want to go hiking
yeah if the if the alternative is write
a joke because i feel like the
that it answers the next question the
next question is what's your most
treasured memory
okay number 17. you go i know you
answered you said it goes
my most treasured memory is writing
jokes to people
um like the
j like i won't say which ones but with
dave
going hey hey you think
so-and-so could do da da da da da like
that's [ __ ] hilarious or jost or
seth or mullany
or ellen or rock or like that's a real
like these moments that's a thing yeah
and not even
you both know how [ __ ] funny it is
and
it's like wow we just discovered
something yeah
it's like it's like archaeologists yeah
no it's like holy [ __ ]
that and so that and i love it and i
love the thing and it's like the best
part of my personality so yeah i
actually i'm getting choked up talking
about this
not even kidding
so yeah that's and that's what comedy is
to me
that's sweet um my most treasured memory
is
so after my dad passed away i went to
panama and i felt very like
lost and just floating and there was
and i made friends there and they all
had beach houses
coincidentally my best
[Music]
and so um there was the bioluminescence
happening mm-hmm
and we were just it was
we just woke up once a new moisturizer
is it correct
yeah it's from the um algae glow neon
and uh we were just swimming in the
ocean at like 2 a.m
and it was warm and everything was
glowing bright green
and every splash was like splashing
overs and it just felt like
like i don't know like it's gonna be
okay maybe it's cheesy but
it did feel
like i it was like i felt normal for the
first time yeah i just felt like
i don't know that like none of the
things in my head matter
like you know it'll you're gonna still
find enjoyment you're going to still
find how long after i was like six
months i can't remember
so what were you like what was the six
months before it
like bad
just bad just terrible was the worst
time of my life so
was it and it was all
it was all stemmed from your father die
yeah something from my dad passing away
and
just being really like shell-shocked
and how old were you uh in my early 20s
and just being really shell-shocked um
and not really knowing how to process it
did he die suddenly
no no he had cancer but it just like
i don't know he it just like it kind of
dwindled quickly and i was still in
college and i had to keep flying up and
it just it was a lot
and i don't generally put
any of the problems i'm having outside
of myself like i
keep them very close to myself whatever
i'm dealing with i don't like call
people like
i need advice like you're never gonna
find me doing that yeah
maybe with like a i love bitching about
small things but real things i'm like
no uh and so it was just really hard for
me to
find how to get the feelings out and
like
mourn and and i think i didn't know
i didn't have the skill set so i
just kind of went into like i think a
state of shock
like for months i forgot
he died for a lot of it like i had to
remind myself
and it was just like it was it was hard
because it was the first time i like
realized i'm mentally not coping with
something you know
and so it was just uh it was bad and
then it was
after he died like a lot of other things
i won't get into was just
worse and i kept thinking like man how
[ __ ] up is it that the worst part of
my dad dying is not him dying
like it's that fallout it's dealing with
a lot of family stuff and
i don't know me and my brother just just
kept our heads high and we didn't
let it get us down like i'm trying not
to get emotional right now but
it was not doing a very good job right
now but it was really bad
and it was hard to
see the good part of things so
when we when i was in panama it just was
nice it was nice to feel like
okay like this is just shitty and it'll
pass
and you're not going to like lose
yourself like those things you know you
have to just go through yeah but it was
it was rough
it was really rough yeah
which brings me to number 18.
[Music]
uh what is your most terrible memory
answered it you go
most terrible memory
uh well there's it's almost like two
categories of
bad what what it's like what was
actually bad
and what did i think was bad okay or
what was the most
emotional like um immediately
emotion bad emotionally i would say it's
a
the it's more a period which is
the period between
the la
the from like june 2004
when championship got super popular i
guess it was
it was april 2004 or may
where it was like p it peaked and then
our contracts were up
the from there
until 2004 april to
2000 may june 2005
the worst it almost every day was awful
this is just me
to just [ __ ] a disintegrating
relationship based on
and disintegrating based on money and
uh respect and and uh
values and just
awful yeah awful and then culminates
in him going to africa yeah like that
and so then
you'd put another year on that so let's
go from
may 2004 to
2016. yeah 2006-7 just
like the worst and
it's like if you're like it's so i
remembered somebody i was at
i was at a nick new york knicks event
which is another thing i forgot to
mention that i'm an absolute sellout to
like i'm never i almost tweet [ __ ] about
the knicks
and i remember like you know those
quartzite seats are pretty good
yeah be quiet how badly do you want to
ship like
it's too much fun and too nice um
i was at some nick thing and somebody
said like
something they said something about in
this is like probably a little after
dave left
and he said something about like me
being famous and i looked at him like
famous and he goes
well infamous i was like infamous way
worse
like what like what do you guys
think of me like it was just this weird
thing like what
infamous like like [ __ ] like uh
like the when when i pulled off the
saint valentine's day right i was like
prohibition on the uh
true tv infamous he did a sketch show
that disintegrated uh i don't remember
his name i feel like his name is
frank and he was the head of publicity
can you imagine just
it's the infamous like in in to every
famous person they're going to be like
infamous it was so like
nothing about that's good uh so that
that was a very dark just
pitch black dark yeah and then yeah
yeah so yeah that was the worst
it's a one two year memory yeah
it's just when you get in those phases
it's like
is they're good yeah and i also don't i
don't have a brain that gets
i don't have like a i'm not like
predisposed to depression or anxiety or
any of that
so when it gets so dark and you you're
not even used to it how dark it gets
yeah like in a way you're in a better
position because you're like oh i
this is just this is going to get worse
like i know i can cycle out of this you
yeah i'm like
what hello where's my happy stuff those
are the things
that i wish i knew if i could tell
myself like
you'll get you're gonna get through it
it's gonna be it's not but there are
periods where you're like
oh i'll bet i won't i will bet you i
will yeah like
i will not be able to shake this feeling
how will this feeling
ever how could it possibly be so shitty
it's so
dark and it's so ugh okay
but it's this is a i maybe shouldn't say
this
but you're falling in love with me
you're falling in love with me
when me and dave see each other
in like anywhere parking lot you i don't
know if you'll be catching the camera we
both go
why because it's so charged
the whole thing is so charged oh yeah
you guys i've seen like
uh like the like we both like [ __ ]
shake and it's all the positives and all
the negatives every single time we see
each other
you couldn't like you you i mean you saw
us
like private i don't think you saw see
each other though
i think i have at the store and it's we
literally i don't know
invisible but we both well it doesn't i
would never interpret it as what you're
saying but now that you say it i'm like
oh
i could actually see that like that like
oh
neil like that being like more but
that's how he plays it
he plays it like oh he plays it like
bluff now that you're doing it i'm like
oh
you're both just like it's like we both
goes yeah it's good we could go
if you knew that in one year you would
die suddenly would you change anything
about the way you're living now
why
the kovid's not great for this because
it's like
this might happen go to the store more
um i guess
[Music]
um let's say no kovid i don't think i
would
because i i specifically
tr i i've talked about this before like
i'd rather
be um
[Music]
i'd rather i'm i'm playing i kind of
think about i don't
go like last day of my life but any job
i get i got this
probably this might be the last money i
ever make yeah why are you so obsessed
with death
death or living uh because
are you asking me do i have the new york
times obituary um
bookmarked on my browser yeah
that's weird i'll tell you why
you know what stoicism right yeah it's
an outgrowth
there's a there's a um sect of monks
that uh they
meditate over dead bodies because it's
just a
good reminder that it's
[ __ ] is finite it will end it's even
looking i don't look at it i probably
look at it once every two months
um but it's just a good reminder
like hey man the [ __ ] you think is
meaningful
probably isn't and
even when someone dies like new york
times
there will be people that were really
important
[ __ ] important people who just died
yesterday
i mean every day there's somebody who
invented an amazing thing or
had really significantly impacted the
world and no one's cared for 30 years
i know i the other i think it was during
covet or maybe it was right before
a neo moriconi any more conan oh anyone
more accounting
yeah greatest composer of all time yeah
he passed by
by he's first second third fourth and
fifth he's
so [ __ ] amazing and he died i think
this year last night
daniel moriconi is the guy and he
and it was like it was like a small
little
and he's so impactful he's like my
favorite song in the world like i love
best songs
and best samples best samples best songs
by soundtracks best everything
um and he's so revered but
also like it was like a blurb yeah
it was during covet i think i think it
was but and it hurt
me so i'm like why i would i wish
we could that's like an outpour like i
want to hear maybe a song i never heard
i want people to post their favorite
like the same i don't [ __ ] know but
he just
kind of turned into yeah nothing and
if you didn't know him it wouldn't you
wouldn't know
and if you knew him it'd be sad and you
know whatever so
and also what do you do it's like yeah
he was [ __ ] amazing and
i don't know what to do now because it's
not like i'm
appreciating him or my connection with
him and his music is any different now
that he's dead
no he might as well have been he might
as well be alive or any might as well
been dead that the whole time exactly
so it's funny there's this gun i was
just going to say that
it reminds me to have fun
that's it it reminds me to pursue the
things i'm interested in
because ultimately even if i accomplish
this great thing
it's just going to be a blurb in the
paper
so just [ __ ] enjoy it just enjoy
yourself just do what
you do do that though i feel like now
probably more than yeah
that's why i go to singapore and [ __ ]
tokyo and
uh where else have i gone uh ventura
county
um by the way i'm doing stand up in
ventura county i believe september 26th
it's legal yes it's illegal
ventura county and i don't think maybe
it'll be trumpy i don't know
i don't think it will be no i'm just
saying it's trump county did he win
no it's just have you been to ventura
yeah it's i think it's in the town now
the town's kind of cute
um september 26th i don't know how to
get tickets i don't know anything about
it i just told the guy on instagram last
night
uh what's your what would you do
yeah well let's just pretend it's
non-coveted
i don't know like i don't like what i'm
doing now i guess if i knew it was gonna
end i would
i would have to change everything about
if i knew i would change everything i
would just go
travel i'd travel till i die and then
spend the last
yeah that's the but the thing about
traveling
is sometimes i wonder if i'm
when i said my most cherished memories
or my worst memories
neither of them are travel based do you
know what i mean like i'm glad
i've had a [ __ ] i'm i
love having a relationship with cities
from just
walking them like i love that but
and they're like they're they're really
nice memories
but i feel like the point of
life is to is personal connections
so i wouldn't i almost wouldn't travel
if that means well i have a dif i
probably have a different
relationship to traveling than you like
i've been traveling alone since i was 16
and i feel just the most connected to
the world when i'm traveling
dis or most connected the most connected
yeah
so um yeah i think i went to germany
alone for the first time when i was 16
and i spent like
the whole summer there didn't know
anybody i went with my friend who
used to live there but i didn't know
anybody i didn't know german and that
like connection to it i just felt like
that's why i always travel it's
it like centers my brain yeah that is
when i feel the most clear and connected
and that's
why i'm really not copying about
numbering but i i really do feel there's
something about
getting out and i don't also when i say
travel i don't
st i'm not like luxury i go where i know
people i stay in their house
for the most part i mean i'll splurge on
a hotel here and there but
no i'd rather do experiences so
i i would just travel till i die that
just
that would be perfect to me yeah i
feel i will say when i travel i get
more medium-wide shots of myself like
look at me an adult in tokyo
i mean like there's that part of it that
is a bit
it's a bit like a child's orientation in
the world and like
look at me i already got toe to you sir
and like
so i can't say that i
i love i like traveling a lot i like
really do
like i before covered i was we were
we were doing a travel podcast yeah uh
but
i don't i almost wish i could
if i was dying first of all i would
to contradict myself bring it up
constantly
um i'm dying you know i'm dying uh you'd
be bumping people
you'd just be like i'm gonna go home
come on when are you scheduled to die
um uh
so but i would want to i would almost
rather
not like a death bed but like if if i
could just
the almost like a movie scene where like
everyone comes
but over a year like uh
where are they not like where are they
now like here comes jost
okay and then jose hangs out for five
hours
[Music]
no and i'm just saying it's just funny
it's like come visit old
dino yeah for your five hours yes
just like to visit that's how i picture
i picture a big part of death to me is
like so-and-so's here to see so-and-so
all right fine cinnamon um it's funny
there was
someone that i know very loosely
not not a tight connection at all and i
got a mass email
because this person was getting surgery
and um
was gonna need to be in the hospital for
some recovery time
and the email was just how to schedule a
visit
i literally started i'm like i'm never
this is the most cherished email i have
i have some cherished emails that i make
a folder of it's just
kind of so disconnected yeah uh and
that's one of and it was like
so these are the instructions i'll only
have these days please call this
president
the whole email was about how to
schedule not if i wanted to
or hey how are you doing it was a mass
email
it was so weird i was just really funny
i can't wait for you to tell me who it
was
as soon as you get as soon as it stops
final question of
part one of neil
and bianca fall in love
the question is
what roles do love and affection
play in your life
um pretty broad gotta be honest
i know i'm like
uh what love and affection affection i
think
means more to me than
i love love affection love is so
nebulous affection's like
i know exactly what i know what the
things are
yeah it's like well is your house
haunted or is there a poltergeist
i want to see some [ __ ] move like do
something you know what i mean
here's how to tell if your house is
haunted
it isn't um jimmy
what what do you mean i mean
like a poltergeist is the type of ghost
that
moves [ __ ] or does is that love or
affection
that's affection okay some people like i
get a weird vibe
that's love i get a weird vibe from this
survive love
in a lot of ways is
promissory it's a it's like you know if
something's something
yeah i'll something something a lot of
times they won't
yeah a lot of times it's like it truly
is promising i have your back man i love
you
you know yeah um i said somebody i was
talking about it was like
a friendship that i felt like i'd paid
my insurance dues and then when i needed
coverage they're like oh you don't you
don't get covered like when people get
like um some sort of disaster insurance
and everybody cashes in and it's like
no money you saw spike's levy when the
levy breaks
from about hurricane katrina but
terrance blanchard
stad who paid insurance to all-state or
prudential or him for 40 years in a
house in new orleans and he got like 235
when it got flooded and it's just that i
cried the minute i was like that is
one of the least [ __ ] fair things
i've ever seen in my life could he
like what was the reason no no record uh
just they don't cover
they don't cover oh they found a way or
whatever it's like they don't cover
it's so funny because in so much
underwriting and insurance it's like
duns doesn't cover act of god it's like
this doesn't cover
the [ __ ] you needed for act of god is
what i'm covering you idiot
like anything's an act of god you know
but that's like well
how are we supposed to cover you for
this random act it's so funny it's
[ __ ]
um it's such [ __ ] the
so i think affection is
this goes to the kind of the power thing
or like the service thing
um because i don't the a lot of things
that people consider
love i consider inconvenient meaning
when people go i'm going to come and
support you
at your show i'm like or like i'm doing
a tv show
a lot of times agents will go i'll be in
your dressing room like i don't [ __ ]
want you in my dress i need to be in
your focus
oh my gosh i don't want you there
and they think it's rude or whatever but
it's like i'm working i don't want you
my cousins hanging out right eating
crudity and going like
oh right killing it buddy um
so that what people consider love it's
like just [ __ ] rub my head
you wanna you wanna make my life better
rub my head yeah i don't need
rub my head and then people get a love
language
i mine is touch more than
more than mine is active service oh yeah
that's like
i don't want to do them and i don't want
them i don't i remember i
screamed at a girl because i didn't want
anything for for my birthday
and she got me something anyway and i
was like i and i didn't want it
i didn't want the thing she got me
that's the thing if you're gonna get
someone who's like don't buy me gift
buy them what they want or you will use
even if they didn't ask at least it's
like okay whatever
but don't buy them something they don't
just just what it's just nonsense
give me a hundred bucks um what was the
present
it's i'm almost embarrassed say it
for her say it don't tell me it one it's
the newspaper from the day i was born
did you get it at six flags where'd you
get it i'd prefer
it's framed it's just all bad it's oh my
god is a framed
so it's just not and i remember didn't
even really
now i have to perform gratitude for a
thing i didn't
silly um that's so funny so gratitude
whereas
in persian culture it's like all it is
is performance art
yeah it's all performance art so i would
rather
love to me is
taking my word for it yeah taking my
word for my preferences
and not going like wouldn't you rather
wouldn't you hey
i'm telling you rub my head
do stuff in my pants
now i'm on the phone i'm taking a phone
call [ __ ]
no i'm a don [ __ ] don't you get it
uh but the the
time i don't you know i the time
[Music]
i don't need you to do chore i don't
like i
got this thing because then i'm like i'm
gonna have to get you that yeah
it just i don't the rubbing is like i'll
be i'm very affectionate very touchy
um you'll get you're gonna get it back
and the good thing about rubbing is you
can do it together you can hold each
other's hands
and it it takes care of each other and
it
actually a lot of people go like i i
like doing [ __ ] for people
i can but i don't get fulfilled by it
yeah i understand that people do yeah by
like i got you what that
drove to the that's how i am like yeah i
just think of people i'm like
invite you to the shirt like just
regular friends
yeah got you this shirt i just like it
yeah sometimes i'll get people's stuff
but
but it's just how it was raised i think
just yeah i don't but it doesn't i
it's fine people are different i got
bijan a shirt in japan that it took me
forever to get it
it's just for me
love is straight up like
i like to feel it yeah i don't need to
say it all the time it's fine if you do
but feel how do you feel it
oh just um you know when someone
i think i think love
you can be nice everybody but i think
it's just differentiating how they treat
you
you can feel that it's like there's a
certain amount of energy
that i'm only giving to you yeah there's
an i i i
as much as i ask it it is i do know that
it's like an element
right you can you know when someone
loves you and they don't have to speak
and that's fine i feel it it's i exactly
i love it
um i love affection affection's great i
really hate hand-holding
uh i think it's a sensory no i get it
it's annoying to people i want to hold
arm uh i had a girlfriend one time
or a girl i was dating who would hold me
by like the scruff of the
we heard one of the greats that's
a great feeling to me ooh like uh like a
kangaroo and a peppers
um papoose romeo what's going on
papoose is uh that's not the thing
though
not the right the rapper is named after
the kangaroo i think it's a
bad boost this is actually hard look at
this
yeah it's like the pouch will you say no
yeah you can't you literally just type
it in and let us do the work
read that uh what does that say
a child
there's a papoose there's someone with
kangaroos
i don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking oh my god wait that was so funny
um so i
really now at this point in my life
i like to feel your love i want to feel
like you want to be around me you want
to have sex with me you
are a good listener obviously that goes
both ways i'm just saying what i want to
feel
but also autonomy and not like that
take my word for it dude i don't have to
tell you 10 times i'm not mad at you
i will tell you i'm a straight shooter
don't
like you don't need to constantly be all
over me like let me breathe
let's come together and have fun i don't
want it to be a
requirement that i do this thing for you
or that you do this thing for me do the
thing
because that means you're my girlfriend
it's like or just go to your friend's
party
like go have fun you don't eat me here i
wasn't there when you were born
and that's the conflict of love
languages it's like well if
you're if my love language is touch
and yours is acts of service
then i'm like [ __ ] i gotta [ __ ] when
i gotta pick up a cake
please i know i you and it means
so much to you and it's legitimate and
just as you know like or i want to hold
hands you're like it's [ __ ] icky to
me and i'm like i
but i find a thing you know like to me
it's also like
let's say we are dating and i don't love
this sort of [ __ ]
and you don't love acts of service
because you're like why the [ __ ] am i
doing this
if we go out and you pay your active
service boom
oh then i got you that's what i'm saying
like i'm a low maintenance love language
person
and then i would just if i mean you were
dating i would be like all right well
i'll just step it up if that's what you
want i mean i'm really easy like yes
i guess it's it's how much of what your
partner
is or can be how much of that should be
premeditated on their part meaning how
much of it should be natural
and if can you learn to
enjoy someone else's love language even
if it's not yours
because i don't think i would ever no
i would never get to a place where i
want to pick up cake
no that's fine pick up the cake i just
pick up the bill and you're good
that's fine that's what i'm saying it's
like it's not always this
thing in your mind but i think as long
as
you know the hangout and the connection
is strong like i feel like the love
languages will
adjust to a certain degree and some
don't adjust and then you talk about it
and some do adjust like i think
the level language could be really
strong and your connection could be weak
and then we wouldn't be talking you know
what i mean
we could both like acts of service and
both like physical touch
but then like both have compatibility
issues still
yeah so i think it's like not the right
thing to concentrate
i realized recently with women you i
mean it's
it's an old thing of like four play
starts at dinner or whatever
like when you pick her up or whatever
but i realize that
how much
present energy does for women
like real [ __ ]
take you down to chinatown right like re
that's it you don't you almost have to
it's almost like putting a woman in a
trance
of attention to the to where they it's
they it'll make you more sexual but it
also
it's invaluable right it's in it's you
cannot put it i i don't think there are
many women whose love language
isn't attention or time yeah
um i've been here who needs he needs me
to
go um rent
a uh uh uh karaoke system
for the party i actually have a portable
one
so he don't need it i don't all right
that ends
part one of neil and bianca
fall very much in love
fun time good time
worth doing she holds you by your elbow
fat elephant toe i don't mind
um worth doing for anyone worth doing
for any friend
right i think um
and i think with a girlfriend or
boyfriend i think it would be
great because it is right you get too
very direct
yeah and it probably [ __ ] you re
like forget about and then there's stuff
about your dad that i
didn't know i didn't know or
yeah or even the letter that was very oh
that's [ __ ] incredible i mean that's
[ __ ]
very rarely do you get to see someone's
rosebud that's actually the sled
that's actually the [ __ ] sled
uh that i had my mom like laminated
probably 10 15 years ago
so funny i remember one point whitney
was like you have to throw that away
you're like no it's too [ __ ] funny
it's like it's too funny to not have
around your house
um all right very good god bless
see you next time bye we don't have to
take the [ __ ] oh yeah we don't think
[Music]
oh
[Music]
um
[Music]
you